Tony Dungy the hall-of-famer joining us
on the program good morning Tony how's
the family good morning we're doing well
we're trying to just hold the fort not
being able to go see other people and
that's got my kids a little cabin fever
is but all or not we're doing great how
many kids are in the house right now
eight right now Mike we can't go
anyplace else
anywhere we can't beat anybody what's
the barbershop talking about barbershop
is fired up they think we're going to
the Super Bowl and everyone's excited
about this acquisition the feeling that
you know Brady will not only you know
play well but elevate everybody else's
game and you know they're they're
excited for the first time in a long
time and you of course live in Tampa but
what was your initial reaction when you
found out Brady was going there
I was surprised because I didn't think
this would be a destination spot for him
but when you look at everything and what
they have in place they've got a lot of
weaponry on offense Todd Bowles is here
the defense played better last year the
only negative is you know you're in a
tough division and they're gonna have to
deal with the Saints and try to get over
that hump but all in all when you stop
and think about it other than maybe that
the offensive line which wasn't great
last year everything else is in place
all right let's go around the league
with some of the other things that
happen first of all Jameis Winston Cam
Newton on the outside looking in if you
had to take one I think you take Jameis
because of the youth and health right
now cam I love Cam but you know I
haven't really seen him at full speed in
a year hopefully he hopefully over all
the injuries and if you got that and you
know you've got some weaponry but not
knowing if I had to choose especially in
this environment where you're not going
to get a lot of information I think I'd
take Jameis Winston and try to try to
work with that I said even before that
the Bucs decided all this you know you
look at Jameson's numbers and Peyton
Manning's numbers in those first five
years
there's not a lot of difference other
than Peyton's team one more Payton had
you know a lot of interceptions he had a
lot of things that that he overcame but
his second five years were tremendous
and I think Jameis you know maybe could
have done that
the other thing Payton had was he had
the benefit of been in the same system
same offensive coordinator for five
years and Jameis didn't have that so
there's a lot of things you could say I
think the young man is talented we'll
see what happens
you got the Patriots situation Brian
Hoyer wasn't good enough to start for
the Colts who brought in Phillip Rivers
but he might be good enough to start for
the Patriots explain that well you know
we're going to find out with the
Patriots if it was a you know system and
scheme and coaches and everything or how
much Tom Brady had to do with all that
and and that's where we'll see Bill
Belichick has had success he won with
Matt Cassel he's won with Jimmy
Garoppolo he's won with Jacoby perset so
we'll see what happens I'm not going to
shortchange the Patriots and say it
can't be done we'll have to see Phillip
Rivers one-year deal with the Colts what
are the Colts doing you know I think
they're loading up on on this year and
you know I thought Jacoby Brissette
played well at the beginning of last
year and then you get all the entry
Ebron went out T wide Hilton was hurt
the backs by the end of season Marlin
Mack was injured and banged up a little
bit they've got a good offensive line
they've got quality skill position guys
I think they're looking at Phillip
Rivers being that that guy who can maybe
take them to the promised land this one
year and then see what happened but you
can you see you scenario where Andrew
Luck comes back
I really can't knowing Andrew I don't
know him that well but I think his
decision was well thought out I think
there was a lot of mental pressure on
him there's the fact that he was getting
hurt a lot and I think he just made the
decision it's time to step away and I
don't think he made that lightly I don't
see him you know all the sudden sent hey
I took a year off and my body feels
better and now I'm coming back
if he thought he might do that I don't
think he would have called it a
retirement in the first place he was
said I'm stepping away for a year and
seeing seeing what happened so I just
don't think he's coming back personally
he's Tony Dungy - Hall of Famer on loan
from NBC Sports I'm also trying to
figure out some situations here like the
Rams and the running back in general
because I my philosophy has been I'm
gonna use you up for five years and then
I'm gonna move on like if I'm Dallas I
wouldn't have reached signed Ezekiel
Elliott with that offensive line I can
get a quality running back in there
you're seeing what happened with the
Chargers in Melvin Gordon the discount
that he had to take to go to Denver
Devonta Freeman now you got Todd Gurley
you know limping out of LA to go to
Atlanta here and what is the future of
the running back the true running back
late you know if you're looking at what
is going on right now
it is this going to be what a running
back looks like in five years I think it
really is I think you're seeing a game
shift to a quarterback offensive line
skilled position guys and then you plug
in a running back the days of Jim Brown
or Walter Payton and we build everything
around that I think it's over you can
look at the cold situation in the last
15 years and Edgerrin James was
definitely a Hall of Fame guy and
Marshall Faulk was a Hall of Fame guy
but they started with Peyton and
Marshall Faulk and you put Peyton
Manning and a bunch of gifted receivers
and that running backs going to have
opportunities so hey Marshall Faulk gets
too expensive
we let him go we draft Edgerrin James
Ezrin James has two phenomenal years and
five really really good years we let him
go the year he was injured Dominick Rose
gets a thousand yahrens okay
and we let mars we let edwin go draft
Joseph Addai he leads the rookie running
back he gains a thousand yards you let
him go and plug in the next guy and
Donald Brown and it works because you
have Peyton Manning and you have those
receivers so I just think that's going
to be the value of the running back
position over
people are going to say you know what I
can trap the guy and maybe I can't draft
Ezekiel Elliott but I draft Marlon Mac
and and he produces for me just fine as
long as I had the other elements well is
it easier to find a wide receiver or
running back now in the drum I think
it's easier to find a running back you
know those those gifted wide receivers
that's what you want that's what
everybody's looking for that's what
you're going to pay for and you know if
I was the Cowboys I would definitely pay
to Mario Cooper and just say you know
what if I don't have Zeke I'll get
someone yeah I don't know what the
Cowboys are doing they're going to be in
salary camp he'll hear toning and you
know they're they're building the to try
to win one and it's been very philosophy
I need the one in Super Bowl and they
may be able to do it but I don't know
that it's going to sustain long term
they're going to have to keep turning
over personnel but this is a team that
didn't even win a you know broken
division last year tone I agree with you
I think they're talented enough to do it
now they they had some injuries too and
that's the thing when you shoot for one
year you get one injury and it's you
know it goes up in smoke that's why I
think you're you're more suited to build
for the long term and try to be good for
five or six years and then you want a
couple of times in there but if you put
all your eggs in one year's basket a lot
of things can go wrong
yeah I think that's what happened to the
Rams I think that the Cowboys are headed
in that direction where you you load up
you know it's almost like you got a five
year window and then after that your
quarterback gets paid and you start to
lose players and then used to have
patchwork you know lineups there and I
think that's gonna happen to Dallas I
don't know what dak Prescott is holding
out for like how much more does it 1
million is it 2 million more per year
because you know mahomes is gonna come
in and you know blow him out of the
water deshaun Watson is gonna make more
I just don't know like what is a good
value for dak Prescott you know I think
boy you know Tom Brady really showed us
if you try to win and you make it so
that your team can have those other
weapons
and you win everything is good for you
as a quarterback you're going to get the
endorsements you're going to make money
you're going to be in situations where
everybody's looking at you because
you're winning and that's something you
can't forget about and the agents can't
forget about well Dax getting that
nailed Tony dak makes great dad Cowboys
quarterback makes a lot of money off the
field and that's where you know what you
should make all the money you can make
but if I'm dak Prescott how much more do
I need to make in you know do I want a
three-year deal guaranteed a five-year
deal guaranteed get your money no matter
what you get it's not you know in two
years from now we'll look back and go
you know you're the eighth or ninth
highest-paid quarterback in the game I
just I'm curious about that and yes
Jerry does want to win and I just I
think he wants to win so bad one more
that you might put you know the future
of this team in doubt yeah yep no I
agree the people don't know you play
defensive back in in the NFL with the
Steelers and I was curious the best
running back you ever tackled or at
least tried to tackle I would have to
say Earl Campbell in my time there
Walter Payton was in the league we
didn't play them every I only played
against Walter want but Earl Campbell
was a guy you you just you had a lot of
gifts for your defensive lineman that we
can you guys get it going don't let him
come through with a full head of steam
it's the second thing he was so I mean
he's just different and and his shoulder
pads I mean I think they would be
illegal game today there was so big but
he carried them well and great guy too
you know was just a tremendous guy but
you didn't want to see him come through
the line with a full head of thing good
luck there with all of those kids and
kind of love your wife hope Laurens
doing well yeah we're holding the fort
down and we got Brady mania here so
we're all good has anybody bought a
Brady Jersey yet our kids have tried we
haven't been out we don't get able to
get out but they've definitely seen them
and
you know we're onboard we're thinking
Superbowl all right thank you Tony good
to talk to you about it
that's Tony Dungy hall-of-famer